jennifer lopez is showing off her new
bling after marrying ben affleck it's
exciting it's exciting one day after
tying the knot with the actor in a late
night ceremony in vegas on saturday j-lo
confirmed the news with this photo from
bed that's the actress makeup free
having a cozy morning and more
importantly showing off her new wedding
band in the caption she writes sadie
hashtag if you know you know referencing
the barbara streisand's funny girl song
sadie sadie sadie sadie
married lady
see what's on my hand
the intimate wedding went down at las
vegas little white chapel where the
couple was surrounded by a small group
of friends and family jen gives all the
wedding deets in her on the jlo
newsletter writing quote we did it love
is beautiful love is kind and it turns
out love is patient 20 years patient
it's just a dream come true jlo also
says that their ceremony was exactly
what they wanted we read our own vows in
the little chapel and gave one another
the rings we'll wear for the rest of our
lives they even had bluetooth for a
short march down the aisle but in the
end it was the best possible wedding we
could have imagined one we dreamed of
long ago and one made real in the eyes
of the state las vegas a pink
convertible and one another at very very
long last the bride shared these
pictures with her groom dressed to the
nines plus video footage getting ready
before walking down the aisle how you
feeling
somebody's getting married
and this
was my
wedding
changing area
it seems second time's the charm for ben
and jen after rekindling their romance
just over a year ago fans will recall
they were previously engaged from 2002
to 2004. you know it's wild to think
about it that way a source tells e.t
they thought getting married in vegas
would be a fun idea
ben is absolutely in love with jen and
feels loved by her too they both feel so
comfortable with each other and like
they share history and know each other
so well baby you're my shelter
shelter from a broken paradise
i couldn't dream it any better if i
tried
and get this jennifer is really making
her love for ben official because she
legally took his last name j.lo even
signed off her newsletter with love mrs
jennifer lynn affleck what can i tell
you we're just having a good time
congrats to the afflecks
[Music]